l horreur
l'impossible deuil cette femme bien
identifié le corps de son fils tué d'une
balle dans la tête par les soldats
russes
s'il vous plaît vous allez avoir le
temps pour lui dire adieu vous ne pouvez
pas rester ici
il était tout pour moi mon unique enfin
dans cette morgue de boudhha les
cadavres se succèdent
plusieurs dizaines par jour une partie
entassés sur le parking une autre dans
des camions frigorifiques
il y a eu plus de 400 personnes tuées
une seule mort ne peut pas accueillir
tout ça ça fait vraiment beaucoup on
reçoit encore des nouveaux corps et il
faut les faire examiner
certains proches de victimes attendent
pendant des heures avant de pouvoir
identifier leurs familles
victoria est venu récupérer le corps de
son mari et le certificat de décès un
document qui prouve que son mari a bien
été tué par les soldats russes la police
m'a appelé pour me dire que le corps de
mon mari a été déterrée quand les russes
l'ont tué on a dû l'enterrer nous mêmes
juste à côté de chez nous aujourd'hui le
médecin a constaté le corps on veut
prouver que c'est un crime de guerre
aujourd'hui elle souhaite enterrer
dignement son mari les obsèques sont
entièrement prises en charge par la
ville un petit geste pour rendre hommage
aux victimes de ce qu'on appelle
désormais le massacre de boudhha